and making his major league debut it's
been much
anticipated
talked about
people were clamoring for shane boss to
get to the big leagues well he's finally
here look what he did at durham in his
10 games the record perfect at 3-0 era
1.76
strikeout to walk ratio outstanding and
he's going to feature a fastball that
can touch triple digits good for seamer
and a good slider off of that those are
the two main offerings and they are
swing and miss pitches
and a cutting
big swing right there and springer out
in front and strikes him out
yeah he ended up going with the slider
there didn't exactly have it in the
greatest of spots but it was successful
nonetheless that pitch is up springer's
swing gets really big so one away and it
will be marcus simeon
ground ball by the mound up the middle
right there is wendell throw to first in
time simeon is out number two the bases
are empty two outs and vladimir guerrero
jr the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss he
struck him out as he blew a fastball by
him and a pretty impressive top of the
first inning for shane boz welcome to
the big 29 year old robbie ray is having
one heck of a contract here he's a free
agent with the blue jays at the end of
the year and he might just walk away
with a cy young this is no less than his
sixth appearance against the race this
year while the rays have beaten him
they've outpitched them they really
haven't hit them hard at all
a shot that's a fair ball
up the left-field line beyond the
bullpen mound diaz on his way to second
and the thrower is not in time head
first and second 20th double of the year
for diaz
that was a bullet that third base umpire
nick lance said was fair and yandy diaz
was on to it and was quick to that
baseball and then galloping around the
bases so rudder at second here in the
bottom of the first and here is nelson
cruz the dh272
two and a slider in on his hands ground
ball to third
runner diaz will hold and lamb throws
out cruz
269 19 homers for the guy who was an
october sensation a year ago
2-2 and a high fly ball to left field
guriel back
on the warning track will make the catch
for out number two the 2-2 swinging a
miss got him with a fastball elevated a
little bit to get the strikeout on
margot and retire the side a lead off
double by yandy diaz and then nothing
else against robbie ray in a scoreless
first inning of work christian hernandez
with one out hernandez 303 on the year
with 28 homers oh one to t oscar a
fastball hit high in the air out to deep
right center field kiermeier gets back
to the wall he stops it's gone
to oscar hernandez with number 29
and the blue jays strike in the second a
one nothing lead
on the long ball by t oscar hernandez
rbi number 107 on the season
after the curveball on the first pitch
he threw a nice curveball but boy that
fastball was up and out over the plate
and watch how he delivers he knows he
got it all as soon as he made contact
look at the hesitation at home plate he
barreled it up and it was a high
fastball he got on top of it not
surprisingly enjoying every bit of it in
the blue jay dugout a runner with second
with a one out and a one one account on
diaz
[Applause]
that is line to left and a catch made by
goriel kiermeier was running but gets
back to second with the throw off line
but what a catch by goriel out and left
i think they found out that he probably
didn't get there it looked like he
stopped before he got to the base but oh
they appealed and they're going to call
them out that's exactly what happened
and the inning is exactly what happened
yeah he went around third he is past
third base there he sees that the ball
is caught and he does not touch the bag
on his way back to second two balls two
strikes through boba chat hitting 294 on
the year 26 homers and 97 runs better
than
boz pitches
ground ball by the mound to short
routine for taylor walls now right
behind the bag a bit of a high throw but
he gets bruschett easily and another one
two three inning rosarita goes to third
let's see if luke lowe can still cash in
ray only with four wild pitches this
year 3-2
and that is just off the plate down an
end
for ball four so the rays have runners
at first and third with two down as the
pitch count continues to climb for
robbie ray 1-1
ground ball up the middle of the diamond
bushet in the shift on the second base
side fields and throws to first to
retire wendell and the rays
they really twist robbie ray into a knot
but he survives leaving the tying run at
third base it's the blue jays one the
raise nothing after
four muriel struck out swinging in the
second 1-1 there's a swing in a line
drive hit deep out to left field turning
around to rose arena watches it go
an absolute laser off the bat of lourdes
gorilla jr he matches his career high
with number 20 and the blue jays have a
two-nothing lead so the two hits solo
home runs and this looked like a slider
that stayed out over the middle of the
plate you can see the spin but it's not
breaking down in a way the way it did
early in the ball game so first and
third one out now the top of the order
jandy diaz he's hit the ball hard twice
tonight
and a drive higher
[Applause]
diaz has hit the ball hard three times
tonight
this time his 12th home run of the year
the reigns lead three to two he's got
robbie ray's number right now and tampa
bay's got the lead look at this pitch is
middle in
almost on the inside corner yandy diaz
has not missed a trick tonight on robbie
ray he has seen the ball well watch the
raised bench on this home run 1-1 for
merriweather swinging a hard ground ball
down to first it's scooped up by
guerrero he'll jog it to the bag himself
to get the out on lao and retire the
side
in this frame one big swing the
difference yandi diaz two out one on one
two
swinging a chopper roll to a third gonna
be a tough play lamb bear hands fields
throws up the right field line
that will score wendell from second
killmeyer now racing all the way to
third and he's gonna round the bag and
now they get the ball here comes
guerrero to the plate and kk is out
rodney linares had put up the stop sign
for him and kiermeier tried to get to
the plate if the rays can take advantage
of the wild pitch pearson ready to go
the pitch breaking ball grounded back up
toward the middle into center field for
a base hit here comes yandee around
third richie's throw to the plate too
late on the second base goes margaux the
rays have added on it's five to two
wendell hit by a pitch last time scored
a run here he swings and sends one way
up into the air into right going towards
the corner hernandez to his left all the
way back to the wall
and go on
it just dropped into the front row and
joe wendell has added to the raised
simeon slugs one of the air out to deep
left field back goes kiermeier at the
wall and it is gone
marcus simeon strikes again a two-run
home run here in the ninth and he's in
there with two outs the base is loaded
this final out so elusive he's ready
there they go the pitch strike three
called game over raceway
raceway
that everybody can breathe out ray's
hold on for a 6-4 win against the blue
jays and the raids win their 93rd game
it was not easy